[Music]
nearly a year after new york city became
the epicenter of the nation's
coronavirus crisis
we're getting extraordinary access to
the ongoing fight to save lives
this morning we're following up with two
doctors who shared the emotional toll
inside the hospital
and video diaries early in the pandemic
now
mount sinai is allowing cameras inside
its er and its icu 2
for the first time mola lange shows us
the progress in continuing peril
of a year on the covet front lines
i think he's about to crash yeah because
of his
sepsis yes sepsis and the respiratory
status yeah
dr umesh godwani is fighting to save a
critical covid patient who has been at
mount sinai hospital for over 60 days
we started what is called ecmo which is
a lung support
therapy it's a desperate
last ditch attempt it's a shame he's so
young it's terrible
[Music]
the somber responsibility to update the
family
in a video chat remotely do you think
they understand how sick he is
yeah you do yeah they think you're not
gonna make it
families unable to comfort their loved
one a cruel symptom of the pandemic
it caused a lot of heartache
not only to the families but also to us
who are taking care of the patient
there is still quite a substantial
burden of
illness and severity of multi-organ
failure
in april gerwani recorded video diaries
to share what battling kovid 19 from the
front lines both
looks and feels like what could we have
done better what could we have done
different could we have saved another
life
the things that i see in the er are
scary
i'm a little scared myself joining in
the fight to save another life
dr matthew bai a physician at the
emergency department in mount sinai
queens
he also shared the emotional toll this
morning when i left the house i said
goodbye
to my wife and my daughter
for who knows how long bai captured the
difficult decision to isolate from his
family at the peak of new york's
outbreak
do you remember where you were mentally
emotionally as you were recording those
things
um it's fuzzy i was stressed there was
times of sadness i felt
lonely there's patients everywhere we're
trying our best to treat everyone that
we can
we followed by on one of his shifts to
see the impact fighting covid19 had
one year later usually the patients get
a bed pretty quickly but since
copenhagen
it's been taking hours sometimes even
days
and so even though we've sort of seen
numbers
fall we're still seeing your hospitals
yeah even though the numbers are down
it's still high enough to keep all of
our hospitals pretty much at like 95
plus capacity if i walk into a certain
room where something
really devastating happened during the
peak i still get like a little
flash of like chills and i can feel my
heart rate going up a little bit
i would imagine it's almost like a
trauma yeah yeah that's a good way to
describe it a survey conducted by mental
health america found
increasing numbers of anxiety depression
loneliness and other mental health
concerns among health care workers
faced with combating the virus but in a
year of devastating lows
there were also highs my wife just sent
me this picture from the park
of her life after six weeks separated
from his family the buys reunited
in august bae's wife gave birth to
another girl in the middle of a tough
day like my wife sends me a picture like
that and i'll look at him
things are looking worse back on dr
kidwani's floor
a desperate attempt underway to save
this young patient's life
the doctors are going to put a test tube
in one of the worst parts of this
pandemic is
how people have to die separated from
their loved ones
never alone never alone our nurses our
doctors
are always there always at the bedside a
year by the bedside
bearing trauma hidden beneath layers of
ppe
for cbs this morning mola lenghi new
york
well i remember guys when tara narula
first brought this to our attention last
year and i remember being surprised
because you think they're doing their
job
they want to be there which of course
they do but i hadn't thought about the
emotional and physical and psychological
toll
he said he walks in certain rooms yeah
he gets chills yeah it comes back to him
yeah
even the helpers need help i can totally
imagine that because those i mean those
weeks what was six weeks away
away from his family where things were
so intense